[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais il se trouve la gadoue vous nous
parlez de paris mais vous deviez donner
vos dernier spectacle à la maison
symphonique la semaine prochaine tout a
été annulé à cause de la pandémie
on va vous rendre hommage aujourd'hui
parce que c'est quatorze ans que vous
êtes à la tête de l orchestre
symphonique de montréal en tant que
directeur musical alors la première
question qu'est ce que signifient ces 14
années pour vous non bien évidemment
c'était un moment très important pour
moi j'ai trouvé québec primo ils sont
carrefour de nous bourrer de newell qui
pour moi était vraiment un grand gang
est couverte et m'a donné une chance de
vraiment à la fois dette dans une
famille où on apprend au passage
certains par l'un et à l'autre côté
liberté totale
nous avons dans nos archives des images
de votre arrivée à l'aéroport
ici à montréal à l'époque qu'est ce qui
se passe dans votre tête
bonjour vous êtes contents des témoins
oui j'ai bien ma femme et moi on rit
beaucoup de 7,7 moment parce que c'est
très clair dans ma tête il ya deux mois
que cette arrivée
1 on n'a jamais vécu un x 2 je croise
était minus 17 minutes devant quelque
chose comme ça j'avais eu pas dans notre
vie comme été
sur ce une source de choc mais tout de
suite après on a fait le deuxième
découverte avec cette première visite
et ça c'était le découvert de grandes
traditions culinaires à montréal
[Applaudissements]
montreal il orchestre symphonique vous
doivent beaucoup
parce que en 14 ans vous avez
démocratiser la musique avec certains
spectacles gratuits on pense aussi à la
musique aux enfants à la magnifique
salle la maison symphonique
mais quel est votre accomplissement
chivu rat le plus fier oui ça c'est une
question très difficile
c'est la même chose si c'est que vous me
demande quelles sont des mails ont foncé
sont les favoris c'est impossible c'est
impossible à dire parce que tous les
accomplissements sont liées à l'une et
l'autre dans un certaine cette instance
un accomplissement sera pas possible
son accomplissement juste avant c'était
tout un tout un chêne d'accomplissement
qu'on a fait en sommes encore une fois
c'est pas uniquement kent nagano et kent
nagano avec les collègues de la caisse
avec l'administration avec le
gouvernement et avec la ville de
montréal je crois après un certain
moment ne publie pas décidé que sera des
choses ce qui était pratiquement
important
maestro nagano tous vos concerts d'adieu
qu'il devait avoir dû cet été ont été
annulés qu'est ce que vous aimeriez dire
à tous ces gens qui sont venus vous
applaudir soir après soir depuis il est
depuis toutes ces années maintenant
parce que j'ai je vous nous faire
pendant ses derniers concerts et du
coeur de remercier tout le monde qui
rappelait le montréal tout le monde qui
province de québec
je suis très reconnaissante
parce que une personne par manny visiter
mais vraiment accomplir quelque chose
mais non il est plein de choses et
maintenant de la matière la maison
symphonique le coeur laurent que tout ça
ça arrive seulement si la communauté
mohawk est tout le monde le gouvernement
tout le monde travaille ensemble vers un
creux mango l'autre chose et vous nous
direz ça devient un grand donneur comme
le public nous considérer comme un
membre de la famille à monde de
communauté et ça ça n'arrive pas tous
les jours
ça m'a touché au fond vraiment au fond
du coeur ma famille aussi
et pour ça j'ai voulu a donné un grand
remerciement en public et tout ce que je
peux dire livre québec ville montréal
maïs croquante nagano merci beaucoup
mais je vous en prie merci à vous
[Musique]